[Music]
Peter Brown right I understand that
you're a fan of classic games you could
say that well you're in luck because I
have 40 of them for you here plus 2 how
does that work
weird a classic games plus 2 bonus
titles
contain on what they were calling the
Sega Genesis mini yeah which we have
right here in a box unfortunately we
only have 15 minutes to play her embargo
we can only capture 15 minutes of video
from this thing yeah I don't think we're
gonna get through 40 games today that's
alright but yeah they set this thing
over you've got one here that you've
been fiddling with a little bit yeah for
about a week now and we've got this one
here that I intentionally have not
opened yet so we can open it right now
all right well we got here you've been
through this tell me what I'm getting
into one of the world is this a USB
power brick
Wow but you can also power this off your
TV your TV's got a USB port most of
these most of these is what first of all
I started to say like this series of
classic consoles even though like every
one of them is made for company sure
like what do we got NES classic Smuts
classic those are you know like
PlayStation classic the Commodore Konami
is making the PC engine traffic stuff is
coming out but most of the bullet power
breaks right that's true they pretty
much stopped including those that is a
tiny little USB brick right there if you
don't have like 20 already from your
cellphone and other stuff what you think
it looks controller okay so rebut and
controller yeah what's going on here
you mean why isn't it a 6 button where's
the other three well ok you'll get at
this very at the library of games on the
system right a lot of them are the older
titles before the 6 button controller
ever came out ok but also if you look at
a lot of Genesis games there's very few
that really benefited from the 6 buttons
that was fighting games basically pretty
much I want to say Ranger X or X Ranger
if you're the name it like yeah like
random games here there yeah there are
solutions to play them on a 3 button
controller and some of those games are
on this system so yeah you're gonna play
Street Fighter 2 you're gonna have to
hit start if you want these buttons to
become either punches or kicks cool yeah
but you know what honestly in terms of
the feel and the performance it's been
great pretty pretty authentic you think
you look like authentic you know I'm in
a while for me I don't know about you I
mean I played your basis yeah I use
specifically analog Interactive's new
controller that a30 the wireless one the
2.4 gigahertz smells so good really like
those things yeah but this is honestly
it feels great it performs really well
and for me the d-pad is always really
important and you can both feel the sort
of switches the activation of the
different directions yeah really well
it's not bad and it's got a bit of
texture to it too which is pretty cool
and I like in game I'm not getting
erroneous inputs on the d-pad when I'm
doing stuff and so often that's a
problem with third-party controllers now
retro bit is a company that licensed
controllers through Sega and made them
earlier this year and Sega's saying if
you want the 6 button controller for
this buy the retrofit USB Genesis
controller but these are made by Sega
these are not made by retro bit okay and
their controllers are good not great
these are great look at that Wow be a
brown Seal of Approval these controllers
and their USB so I guess you can plug it
into a PC yeah you should be able to
yeah I mean certainly you can plug in
any USB controllers you have like I was
playing games with a saturnine oh ok so
there's so anything that has 6 buttons
yes you can just go yes ok what's with
knitting crucially for my nostalgia you
get the good pumping sound on the face
bottom that's exactly what I remember
after these things that right in the mic
ok what is this a USB cable yeah an HDMI
cable instructions and the thing the
thing itself all right well that was a
one hell of an exciting unboxing there
you go so we have a timer loaded trying
to figure out how to use our 15 minutes
judiciously here do you want to pop it
on a look at the menu real quick let's
do it I'll show you how do I try to run
down what is on this thing yeah
Jan I'm gonna rely on you to just keep
us in check here we can talk about a
couple interesting things as it pertains
to like specific games
first okay taking the music this is a
Samba done by user cashier oh wow okay
anyone who doesn't know the composer of
many give me any games but most notably
Streets of Rage up a series yes and
revenge of shinobi one of my favorites
oh yeah this uh this song is made using
songs from the games that are on this so
cool so it's kind of sampled in that way
that's cool
so yeah the interface is as such there
is a way I don't member offhand someone
else was talking about it where you can
actually flip it in so you see the
spines let's go ahead and see all the
games but you can come in here and
change the language and then if you back
out oh wow oh my goodness that's cover
right head okay yeah interesting to note
that some games obviously go by
different names most notably would be
where is it
Robotnik's mean bean machine becomes
Puyo Puyo okay on this so would even
like changes the game entirely well but
so is that the super shinobi that I say
that says it is yes anyway like what I
was gonna say though about monster world
before so any of these games now we're
gonna play in Japanese so that it
actually switches to a ROM based on
whatever you said the language to okay
but that game was never released in the
u.s. although it's got an English
translation when you're playing in
English okay so that's pretty cool to
note they have changed some of the games
in that respect for this system is that
a new localization doing like I think it
was based on I think it maybe got like a
Virtual Console translation I'm probably
misrepresenting that or maybe it was
like a sega ages release that him to
also worked on okay the other cool
options in here
I change the language back to language
whoo nice I was gonna have to try to
remember by Japanese class from college
fully guessing your heart doesn't you go
so you've got the ability to stretch it
if you so wish don't know why you'd
really want to do that I guess the one
example was mentioned by my life and
gaming who probably your readers are a
little bit aware of our viewers rather
one of the best sites I need supra
covering this sort of stuff the way that
the pixels are interpolated for certain
resolutions doesn't always work out as
you prefer so I don't wanna get too
technical but essentially there is a
reason why you might want the widescreen
and have your TV squishing this is an
enthusiast matter so sorry if you might
say sorry
they have the plain black border okay I
could have these two weird ones black
for me that's pretty much it okay so
pretty bare-bones yeah
alright so games on here let's talk
about I guess I guess let's just play
whatever you think is interesting in
terms emulation or yeah we're rarity or
any of that stuff well you talk about
rarity Tetris yes I like a rare game but
it only four copies were released I
think are only four in existence now or
something like that it's worth about
$10,000 if you hire me there's only in
Japan or there was sweepstakes or
something like that yeah so that one I
was gonna say it is what is a Darius and
Tetris or if it's raining bonus titles
so Darius do you know the story about
Darius being not really know well the
story is somewhat of a mystery
so Darius was never released on the Sega
Genesis about a year and a half ago a
hobbyist whose name I'm forgetting you
know hacker Porter software engineer was
porting the game to Genesis and he was
sharing his progress on forums and
putting up gameplay videos where did
where does the game originated arcade
post up Saturn I think there's also a PC
engine for it but the
I think his port was based on the arcade
version though which obviously had super
wide screen appearance in the arcade
been adjusted for this okay anyway his
work disappeared off the forums where he
had been posting most of the videos and
here it is on the system of course leads
to you know assume that there's some
relationship there yeah they got to him
take it won't really talk about it oh
okay say good won't really tell me the
story and I think it's just safe to
assume that there's been some sort of
business agreement that's just an
assumption on my part they just saw what
he was doing and liked it enough to
maybe move the mill you know em to they
make a series of games called em to shot
triggers like they convert our kid games
and never got home ports to home
consoles and I think this is just right
up their alley and they probably thought
what a really special opportunity for
this product if we're gonna be involved
but into basically is a Japanese studio
that does a ton of emulation stuff and
like kind of for hire is that right yes
they've done a ton of work recently
specifically well forever with Sega but
recently they've been working with
Konami a bunch I believe they're working
on the PC engine turbo graphics stuff
they're doing they did castlevania
collection i will say their work here is
good it's not flawless some of their
stuff like their 3d classics on the 3d s
where they take old Genesis games break
them down and add 3d support and a bunch
of our charitable options those things
like go way above and beyond what you
would expect from a normal port and
choose a really solid technical
foundation but when it comes to like the
special features you'd expect this
doesn't quite have them at large so you
to get back to me I mean you hold down I
thought it was yeah the start button for
a while and then just let it go we got
on the well we could get buttons once
we've exhausted yeah it's fairly spirit
I'm worried but what game would you like
to see oh gosh
I guess maybe is something that's super
familiar just to like I get an idea of
how
yeah oh cool he goes okay I just like
I'm Alex kid like I'm just seeing stuff
that I played back then yeah and put
into I remember the like this is one of
the first games I saw at my friend's
house when he got a Genesis all I had it
was Nintendo yeah and it was alert
because of Nintendo benefits version of
goblins is like yes there was one you're
on with videogames could be more by and
large you know this thing feels really
good as someone who plays Sega Genesis
on a regular basis I'm not playing this
thing and thinking like oh god they
really screwed this up again to save my
life and gaming who does really
excellent work when it comes to
comparing and contrasting original
hardware with aftermarket devices they
were able to pinpoint some minor
differences that I think to someone
whose value will nitpick will say oh
this isn't worth it but really this
isn't for that sort of person yeah this
is some you know this is really for the
person who wants just play Sega Genesis
games and Sega can say hey we put out a
good product you know no one's gonna
jump down into throat for what they've
done right like this is for somebody
seeing this on the end cap at Target and
saying hey I remember the Sega Genesis
yeah this thing is cheap enough I'll buy
this yeah I mean that was the at games
flashback which everyone hated and that
thing probably still sold as well but at
least now no one's gonna be there to be
like well actually if things a piece of
trash and you don't know any better
this thing is you know it's pretty good
like definitely good enough for the knot
and yes kind of hardcore it's good
enough for me and I'm the one who you
know you're talking before we're
shooting like modifying Genesis consoles
to do certain things like even I'm happy
with this I mean I'm gonna you've got a
house full of CRT circuit boards passes
your test yes well I won't uh we'll put
you through the wringer with this game
too much time surviving STIs the
series's yeah sadistic I guess it was
like let's check out Castlevania perhaps
okay pretty good standard like savestate
type stuff I say yep you know
wily Wars is nobody cool game that's on
here cuz I was only on the us in the
second channel okay I was never actually
sold it was in Europe yeah just reading
about that game recently it's what is it
one two and three
uh yeah one two and three and with the
graphics are like redone
yeah it looks kind of weird it kind of
resembles Mega Man 7 which I don't love
the aesthetic of ok I would like to hear
all is value stream the music is all
array is pretty similar I mean is not
very expert in Mega Man music I didn't
catch anything off it was I love the
Mega Man 2 soundtrack yeah I want to
hear the music from that version we can
jump near that after cool yeah
sorry this is this blood Castlevania
bloodlines yes yeah this is one of those
games that was made at Konami and then
some people who worked on it as far as
I'm less I'm getting the timeline wrong
broke off to go create treasure right oh
wow
Oh kid I guess the treasure is mostly
economic huh I didn't know the origin of
treasure yeah
never been in their office no but I've
heard it's incredibly sterile it's a
tiny tiny little basement office yeah I
think we did a shot there before I was
on staff so a long time ago and they
were like it's just white walls yes the
whole white wall dogface very small yeah
as this Castlevania ever appeared
anywhere else like there's it's so easy
to get them all mixed up because like
Dracula acts but then there's kind of
weird half remake have really tight
versions lab and in most recently it was
on the Castlevania collection okay but I
mean back in the day was this Genesis
only or this is justice
and it's a really good one you know it's
one of those that I I was a Genesis kid
by choice and I regretted that choice as
soon as I went over my friend's house
had a Super Nintendo but I think I just
didn't get the right opportunities to
understand the breadth of what was
available on Genesis for whatever reason
and once I finally got back into it this
is one of those games it was like oh my
god how did I not know about this cuz I
like Castlevania on the NES and I hadn't
any ass before Genesis for sure but yeah
this one is just so good in the
soundtracks even the the different like
special effects that are used in levels
it really feels like I mean better than
any of the Super Nintendo Castle I was
gonna say this this or Castlevania for
for you I like for a lot but it's it's
mostly a remake or reimagining of the
first game and it just feels a little
bit basic in some regards this one is
surprising and is you know that there's
like no censorship really like a gory
it's a you have the soundtrack home and
Castlevania soundtracks are all pretty
good like some are amazing this is one
of the amazing ones I think you know to
talk about that like it's great to see
that those are here that this system
hasn't completely mangled the genesis
audio sure there is no definitive
Genesis sound every even within the
model one design there are various
motherboard revisions one yeah I have no
idea so the community in the Genesis
community right now is actually there's
this program led by this guy Artemio
called MV Fourier where they are using
analysis software it's you really
catalog all the different audio
behaviors of the various Genesis systems
and through that we've realized that
yeah like there are I say we I just an
onlooker but yeah it's come to life that
we knew there were some differences but
it's really drastic and so there's a
huge community people who are trying to
create boards to upgrade and get that
best Genesis sound
this is pretty good this falls within
the range of what you'd pull you'd hope
for and what most people am for is the
model ones Genesis to the VA 3
motherboard I would love to see a
comparison to that I don't know them one
of those unfortunately there's any way
to tell which one you have without
opening it up if you have the modeling
to it if you have the model one right
there's the version that has the
high-definition graphics up top okay or
there's nothing like that you know in
the top circle you can see it on this
system yeah
if it doesn't have that it's a later
revision of that and likely not that
great but if you have one of the earlier
ones that has that you can still get
kind of a funky version of the model one
with kind of crappy audio so what you
want to do is look at the back look for
the extension port that's actually like
a serial or a parallel port that you
would like add devices to if it has that
and it says it high-definition graphics
you have a pretty good shot of getting
one of the earlier editions this is
amazingly imprecise but even if you even
if you have one of those right the only
way to get stereo out of your Genesis is
to get it from the headphone port
well the headphone port I'm pretty much
all model ones has like peaking issues
and distortion okay again there's no
definitive there's no perfect Genesis
there's no perfect Genesis but you know
compared to other aftermarket offerings
this one is pretty good if not better
than all the other ones that flashback
put out for sure
[Music]
three minutes really oh god we got time
the gelatin Eggman yes
how about you do it I want you to do
hope we did something that heals sure I
mean I have no bag man expert but are
you interested in this on a personal
level like I'm even more academically
just like it's good to know how these
source products turn out German just for
my kind of a recommendation standpoint
but yeah I don't know I mean there are
so many different ways to play games of
this era at this point I just love it
for being like a little model of a
Janice yeah it's cool like all of these
have a kitschy appeal to them just like
here's every console from my youth tiny
form exactly I wish I could just buy the
shell to be quite honest with you like I
would totally buy those no I did buy the
kinda Hamazon Japan you can get the fake
Sega CD and the fake 32x that plugs into
this thing no kidding have you seen that
stack oh yes in Japan they're literally
releasing relatively sized models that
you can snap it all together don't add
any functionality this pencil that's
pretty much cool yeah I'm not gonna put
the 32x on but the model one Sega CD is
I love the way that thing well that's
that definitely illustrates with the
actual appeal of these things yes which
was just
I'm tempted to sit here and wash we got
a minute 58 seconds okay yeah of course
it's going to sound different too
because it's tuned through the Genesis
audio hardware which is believed in FM
synthesizer and the Yamaha 2612
processor there's also the Yamaha 3438
remembering correctly which is slightly
different and again people have
different feelings on which one is the
best the purest one is the 2612 but the
3438 is cleaner for some people fair
getting in the least
oh wow okay got a little little railing
drawing over top of the sprite wow this
is a nice looking version of magnitude
yeah naturally I went with the canonical
first boss here man yeah this is gonna
keep going yeah go at some point yeah
got a minute Brett oh boy oh God
we'll stop beat the damage I'm logging
later to hear man this is cool I don't
think I don't think I've ever seen this
version because like I said it's not
widely available here a man who's a hell
the game might have to check outs for
this yeah it seems like they've I'll
save that 20 20 seconds I'm not gonna
make it air man ah look I got a little
dolly here you guys yeah no sound would
that sound when you pick up the health
oh that's [ __ ] oh it's kind of you
can kind of hear it just a little bit
Dan just cut in whatever man alright
there's gonna be I'm more gameplay on
gamespot we're actually gonna cutting a
montage of all 42 games under the time
limit okay so you only get a few seconds
of each I know but why do they I don't
know why two minutes yeah we a little
limiting for this many games but yeah I
mean I guess we can't really show more
than that until the thing comes out yeah
there's a second embargo at time of
release September 19th
do you know how much this costs offhand
eighty human bones Edie
it's well that's about in line with my
bad others right yeah and you get two
controllers although that you can use
other devices I like the classic systems
right that give you like the Wii
controller style plug until no one's
were about the same 100 oh no they were
less than 100
oh really I don't member the exact price
point I want to say there were 77 X okay
the police station was like 20 bucks
Smith yeah get into the box would
Cracker Jacks if you look around yeah it
seems like a pretty good lineup you know
it's 42 games and there's some
exclusives per territory um like I think
the Japan model has like Lucia for
example a shooter that a lot of people
love the Asia version the one for like
got Korea and Taiwan that has like alien
soldier on it and Shining Force 2 and
you know it's it I wish they all had all
the same games so I didn't feel so torn
sure
yeah make sure to check that out before
you order one Oh last thing I don't know
if you want me to yank it off of ours or
yours can ASMR at - do I look like a
close-up in this thing I love doing this
especially everything in the world now
we play this thing yeah so the cartridge
slot yep there's a cartridge slot yep is
there a connector in there in Japan you
can actually get a collection of I think
like 20 mini cartridges and I believe
they also come like framed like
suspended in like a shadow box sort of
situation but you take them out and I'd
want that but I think it's very
expensive Condors I think he doesn't go
a couple hundred dollars kind of cool
also I can confirm there's just nothing
but flat plastic it's a lot of a slot
hey hey you can put whatever you on
there it's true anything that fits yeah
that's right um slider actually do
anything no okay unless I unless I
missed it I'm pretty sure that's a no
there's also a door for the Sega CD to
plug in and the bottom if you know
nothing we were mentioning earlier yes
and they seem to have gone gone all the
way with this thing yeah it's pretty
sweet that's that's impressive
especially after the just the whole add
games Fiasco where they put out that
kind of a version of this yeah it was
very compromised yeah I mean I think you
could probably still find that on the
shelves at Walmart or something and this
will be right next to it at some point
so don't confuse that for this
yeah disregard anything made by at games
unfortunately they haven't made a they
haven't made a good product that stands
up to I think the modern awareness of
what retro games should be and how they
should feel right I think that worked
when people when the industry at large
wasn't really trying to get that in
people's hands and now that they are
it's the scrutinies a bit higher
standards have have increased yeah for
sure
well thanks for stopping by thank you
maybe we'll come back and mess with this
thing a little bit more once the
shackles are off
sure and we could play some landstalker
or wow this is some tiny type here light
Crusader maybe the worst game on this
system Wow made by treasure oh I can't
stand it that's depressing it's like an
it's at a really ugly isometric
slow-paced
like Western RPG oh it's weird weird
will speak out on here
Road Rash - hell yeah things got
everything explained that and I was like
guys like 10 frames per second and then
like 20 minutes later I was like oh I
still love this game I don't care it's a
road rash still feels really good road
rash is be honest yeah road rash is
forever
thank you Peter Brown thank you this
thing's coming out September 19 alright
look forward